[Music]
Kiki Palmer's partner Darius Jackson
shames her for wearing a see-through
outfit to an usher concert oh my gosh
Come On Let's Talk About It Kiki hit up
Usher's Las Vegas residency show on the
4th of July rocking a sheer black dress
over a matching thong bodysuit for the
occasion
[Music]
it was such a great experience for me
yeah but Darius didn't seem to be a fan
of the sexy fit retweeting a viral video
of the singer serenading Kiki in the
audience to his track There goes my baby
and writing it's the outfit though you a
mom
[Music]
of course Kiki and Darius welcome their
first child together a son named leotis
in February what has been your favorite
part so far of motherhood you know I
think it's our morning
together you know what I'm saying he's
laughing he's smiling and he's a little
sleepy so I don't have to hit him cries
you know it's just a little bit
everything as for that tweet Darius
doubled down in a separate post writing
we live in a generation where a man of
the family doesn't want the wife and
mother to his kids to Showcase booty
cheeks to please others and he gets told
how much of a hater he is
foreign
[Music]
this is my family and my representation
I have standards and morals to what I
believe Kiki has not publicly addressed
darius's comments but as of Thursday
they're not following each other on
Instagram meanwhile the nope actress is
proud of her fit sharing a closer look
at her see-through number and writing
that she wished she had taken more picks
but they were running late
Kiki also praised Usher's performance
calling it so fabulous
[Music]
and while Darius and Kiki might not be
seeing eye to eye now back in April she
told ET she loves watching her man
become a dad he's just so attentive I
guess that's what you want our fathers
to be but it's even more than I expected
it um I just really am grateful to have
such an amazing partner to do this with
but I think that is obviously why we had
the kid together I saw way before that
he had the dedication of the patience
and what's the word I'm looking for like
um
discipline to be an amazing dad and
that's why I wanted you know to have my
baby with him
[Music]
foreign